six one seven eight three zero 4750
let's go next to our caller from
potentially right here in the Boston
area our caller from six one seven go
ahead hydrate
I can barely hear you and it's also
quite loud in the background so if you
can if you can speak up and also maybe
get to a quieter spot that would be
great are you whispering out of
curiosity and no no whisper all right
god I think I can just barely hear you
go right ahead with your question sir
i'ma try to speak louder how do you hear
me
I can I can sort of hear you yeah go
ahead and hi but imma talk on them I'm
not actually from Boston for area I'm
just using some laughs all right I just
wanted to ask you about the hypocrisy of
left regarding this my next one I just
don't understand why they just want to
defend sorry you're asking are you on a
playground by the way no no garden not
garden you want to ask me about the
hypocrisy of the left
what was that HIPAA hypocrisy of the
left you wanted to ask about about it's
not my big defend a religion that
doesn't respect human rights so who's
doing that who's defending that the left
not you specifically but some social
justice warriors and Ted come on give me
a break is that what what a social
justice warrior mean to you no I'm not
talking like a justice social justice
warrior but no no I'm asking what do you
mean you said that there are social
justice warriors who defer to defend the
brutality of Islam what do you mean by
so who are the social justice warriors I
know it's a pretty internet the an term
from the internet but it just means some
extremist extreme left us to just not
extremists to things it
social or economic census the way but
just in the act entity policy
extensively okay and what do you mean by
identity politics a racial and ethnic
problems in also religious Brahmins
identity politics means racial ethnic
and religious problems I just don't know
how to define it but yeah you understand
listen well there are people that will
defend anything there are people on the
right who are now saying that Kim
jong-un is great there are people on the
Left who seemed to hold on there are
people on the Left who seemed to now
like everybody from you know Hugo Chavez
and Nicolas Maduro who are authoritarian
pseudo populist to Hamas I mean right
you'll find people on both sides that
will defend anything I don't think that
there are any significant number of
people on the left that are defending
brutal actions under the name of Islam
everything exists but it's a relatively
small contingent I'm not part of it so I
don't really know what else I can say i
denounce that to be two totally clear
and sorry can I speak now you can speak
now yes but it's not about you or in
general but about some leftists that I
met and I know I don't block they're a
huge part of the Blessed ya movement in
America but there are in my knowledge
many questions for defend Hamas for
example which is yeah and I'm that's
disgusting in America yeah yeah because
they say that they defend the
Palestinians right which is completely
well Palestinians have right defending
Hamas is not the same thing as defending
Palestinian rights right yeah no they
use excuse of Palestinians and Paula
senior problems to defend some ostriches
right I don't I don't think any defense
of Hamas is is the legitimate listen I
just don't think this is as big of a
problem as I guess you think it is and
it just needs to be called out right
call it out for what it is denounce it i
apprec--
at the call thank you glad we were able
to it really seemed like there was
whispering going on there that's the
impression I was getting think about the
YouTube title now caller whispers about
Islam hypocrisy yeah